[Music]
I'm gonna show you this hysteresis and
I'm gonna show you how to spot issues
issues that we found a plenty of course
but for we're most widespread yes I
would say that these for performance
pitfalls were basically an every game I
so had one two or three of them I've
just found myself saying the same thing
over and over again
I said let's locate by your to him bunch
of other people so I don't have to
repeat myself of it all the time I'm
gonna go in depth on on each one of them
I'm gonna show you these traces and how
to you spot it in your game that's the
first one and this is this race this is
basically insert the number of course
eight in this case and you can see all
the threads running in the system and
you can see these thread number three
which is basically grabbing one core
twos jumping from one to the other but
essential is grabbing one core and
hammering it while the rest of system
does nothing it's that's how a single
thread game looks in series and that is
okay in the sense that if you're making
a casual game a single thread casual
game is the right thing to do I get it
it's just much easier the architecture
is easier everything is simpler you
don't have to look at synchronization I
get it it's a simple thing to do but if
you're pushing the boundaries a little
bit more well you have eight course
you're using one it's a matter of
performance but as we're gonna see later
it's not only about performance this is
an example of a unity game
I'm not gonna ask you many unity
developers are here it's like everyone
asks the same question but I believe
there gonna be many there's gonna be a
unity main thread
single thread hammering a system just
want core everything else does nothing
that's how it typically looks like a
unity and that's actually very very
simple to fix that's it click click I
think multi-thread ready that that one
here just click it it's it's gonna make
your game run faster and be better it
will make me happier since you're there
you you click the GPO skinning as well
because you don't want to skin on the
CPU it's bad and it makes me cry I don't
have a picture for that but imagine it
once you click that that's how your
system is going to look there's gonna be
a nice main thread which is processing
you entity each entity will generate a
bunch of graphics command for a render
thread that will take this graphics
command and in parallel it will generate
a bunch of random commands for the GPU
which ones in parallel now instead of
having a fryer that is hammering one
core you have two threads at least
you're polarizing your work and that's
how systrace is going to look like
you're gonna have unity main it'll be
smaller unity GFX device I don't know
why W I always wondered why this is not
going to give you a double frame right
straight out of the gate because you're
not probably gonna part gonna have
workloads that are exactly the same time
and can be just perfectly paralyzed but
I mean you see it's a pretty decent
difference you're gonna get something
out of it more interestingly you're
gonna let the CPU that is running unity
main have the chance to sleep for a
little bit we'll see why it's very very
important to let
course asleep sounds weird at the end of
the day you want to paralyze your
workloads because they will give you
better performance but also because if
you don't do that that's what happens
higher power consumption that's a direct
consequence of having one single thread
that does everything it means that
you're gonna consume more power you're
gonna drain the battery much faster
which leads us to the second issue this
is a gigantic deal this is a big deal if
there is one thing that I need you to
remember out of here is thermal
throttling as a big deal that's because
on mobile performance is not constant
over time you think I worked on console
MPC pattern console small fun but once I
made my frame take 33 milliseconds to
process I was done I lived in Ingham at
the time everyone was going to the pub
I'm Italian I was having a coffee please
don't have cappuccino after lunch it's
bad
all mobile things are much different on
mobile once you you render 33
milliseconds for a frame here's what
happens you have your curve fully
optimized game you give it to someone to
play it looks great it runs beautifully
for 10 minutes and then this device is
gonna get hot device getting hot means
performance will go down because phones
that explode generally are not perceived
well by clients so manufacturers have to
slow things down so the device can cool
down so your game that was running at 30
frames per second on the clock now is
running at 20 15 10 and your customer
will go and play and write you and 1
star review once the reviews are bad I
have an equation on my slide I know must
look at that power consumption for a CPU
is equal to capacitance thingy see
nothing as a constant of some sort
x squared of the voltage multiplied by
its frequency now you see stress you can
see for each core the frequency like
value is like 2 bigots think and you can
see the thread 3 is basically maxing out
frequency on that core also in order to
run a max frequency the voltage has to
go up as well to maintain that tight
timings in the transistors at least
that's what they told me at the
University 25 years ago but also notice
this very interesting phenomenon the
frequency at some point goes down
because the scheduler decided to lower
the frequency but each core goes down at
the same time you can see like 1 2 3 4
times in a row they all go down at same
time that means that by virtue of every
third
three maxing got frequency in one of the
course and maxing out voltage of one the
course voltage is squared which is like
it's consuming a lot of power it's
forcing that small thread and to consume
a lot of power for a little bit of work
that most probably doesn't need to run
fast if that thing takes ten times to
run you will still hit thirty frames per
second most probably this phenomenon is
clearer here this is a Snapdragon 855
yep remember correctly this has two and
a half clusters of course the small ones
to run at a lower clock clock to three
cores to run a higher clock and there's
another one clock 3 the runs even higher
clock so basically each cluster has a
clock plane and each cluster is voltage
gated that means that each cluster runs
to the same voltage and the same clock
frequency except for clock three they
can run a different frequency from clock
to you interestingly even if it runs a
different frequency from clock to you
they still share the same voltage which
means if the voltage goes up through the
last view three more CPUs go up
everything consumes a lot of power one
big takeaway here course in a cluster
always share the same clock this doesn't
make me happy because it makes my life
harder and yours as well
on the other hand it's much simpler to
design and it's understandable why all
associates are designs why no exception
whatsoever
this is another example this is very
interesting because cpu 0 1 2 & 3 are
little cores 4 5 6 & 7 are big course
now every SOC I've ever seen has the
first course as little course with
smaller caches lower frequencies and the
last for course big course or even
bigger with larger caches higher
frequency much faster and much more
power hungry they all look the same but
please still do your due diligence and
try to understand the topology of the
SOC programmatically there are ways to
do it and we can talk about it later in
the game reviews you should come over
look at that W this is another Unity
game W is a worker thread all these
worker threads are running on CPU four
five six and seven and little cores are
doing nothing effectively these could be
running on a little coarse consume much
less power
and give the big cores more chances to
go to sleep going to sleep means no
power consumed it means lower
temperature in general less chances to
throttle less chances to go into thermal
throttle less chances to get the mice
hot because all phones sooner or later
will overheat and will be throttled and
that's not under control you will not be
told why you will not be told when every
device is different every manufacturer
has its own secret sauce on how to do it
it depends on the environment I mean if
you play in Finland probably for a while
if you play Nidalee nope it's not in
summer especially you have to do
everything in your power which means
sheep as much as possible to be executed
on little course in order to avoid
thermal throttling
at the end of the day distributor
workloads which is very similar from
paralyzer workloads going multi-threaded
will help you with thermal throttling as
well which workload you want to one
where well here's the thing high memory
bandwidth you're reading a lot from the
system memory or you need a lot of cash
to go fast well this kind of workload
goes well on a big core you're doing a
lot of math well lots of math means big
core again because big cores have the
mass instructions little coarse don't so
they're much lower everything else just
set the little coarse and make me happy
this is an interesting statistic this is
numbers on a pixel three a little core
consumes 331 million per peak or 215
it's a seven times ratio which means
that if you have a piece of work that
you move to a little core if that piece
of work takes less than seven times the
time to run when compared to the Bicol
your saving power as long as you run at
30 frames per second you're good that's
the kind of memory model that you have
to think about on the latest devices
this ratio goes up to 20 like it's 20
times more power hungry and it's highly
unlikely they're gonna see workload that
runs to 8 times faster a little core
theirs keep in mind look at the audio
thread
well little coarse I'm doing nothing
that goes straight into a sleepy 0 1 2
or 3 and this is how you do it set
affinity is just a system called it's
pretty too straightforward to do some
code that I wrote I can claim I'm a
programmer now and it just runs a system
call and checks for for errors this is
like super straightforward and this is
how you use it if I want to run on a
little core I set the mask to the first
course if I want to run to the big
course of it I said the mask to the last
course and then I set the thread
affinity super straightforward just give
do not pin a thread to a certain core
just leave some room for the scheduler
to do its work because it's good but pin
it to certain clusters
and now we are probably doing time 20
minutes left I have a volunteer here and
I have my camera this has never been
done before
a Goulet oh please please please please
please come in
I just volunteer you and I'm gonna take
photos of him this is never be please be
serious like do a a more and more
developer like face like a serious one
more more more serious a little bit less
serious look at me look at me
excellent excellent the kasam smile
excellent thank you very much
did I lose the
[Music]
there was the thing the clicker thing
detective it the clicker thing do you
have a clicking thing it's gone
it's amazing I don't know it's gone
sorry no it's gone literally disappeared
but we have another one frame pacing
frame creasing is about a lot about
performance and in systrace you have
this view which basically shows you were
annoyed this latching on your frame and
displaying it there's basically a very
good proxy for when my frame is gonna be
on screen when my user is gonna be
seeing my image and if you see bars that
are not evenly spaced like sometimes
shorten times bigger that is a sure sign
you're having frame pacing issues
this gets a little bit more complicated
like the first bar up there is when your
game is done with the frame and it's
presenting it to the to the system so it
can be grabbed and be displayed the
second bar is a nice V seen coming every
sixteen point six milliseconds 60 frames
per second don't there is the bar that
we saw before just a little bit large it
shows you like the system is doing
something is sending the frame today the
other compositor is doing some work but
the point is that at some point when the
frame is present in the cue our droid
will decide okay I got a frame javi goes
to screen and it took about 50
milliseconds in the first instance
because look at the circle there we miss
the vsync we arrived slightly too late
with the vsync so Android that nothing
to display then or something to display
Android was doing its work immediately
after the game is presenting another
frame so this is a typical example with
game presenting as fast as possible and
then immediately later Android says
great I got the frame how it was to
screen 16 milliseconds later this
translates when you're playing in - I'm
running at 20 frames per second and then
I'm running at 60 and then 20 and then
60 so the user perceived is as choppy
frame rate is a choppy 60 frames per
second one one star review straight away
it's very disturbing generally speaking
a 60 frames per second game that is
choppy as much worse than a stable 30
frames per second that is nice a smooth
and that's how you say it on systrace
but that's enlarges one
I'm slightly large in the the same thing
that we showed before I'm just showing
you also the CPU and we can see that
this frame which is like the big bar
started a couple of milliseconds too
late after everything and it literally
missed by a hundred microseconds it
arrived slightly late by one hundred
microseconds so Android will present
this frame 16 milliseconds too late
because we missed by 100 microseconds we
miss because we started slightly too
late
theoretically this thread would take
less than 33 milliseconds to process the
frame this could run a 34 second no
problem whatsoever but it's not and it's
not because the game is too slow it's
because it's missing the frame pacing
this is the basically the cause of most
frame instabilities that I've seen
because as a game developer you know
that if you want to eat 30 frames per
second you have to run a frame in less
than 33 milliseconds most people do it
because they're good but then they don't
present the right time and the frame
rates still choppy and you have frame
time stability but not only another
issue is imagine a touch input that
comes when the first frame that takes 50
milliseconds to be displayed well this
is gonna be showed 60 milliseconds later
so I touch and I see the result of my
touch 60 milliseconds too late and then
I see the result of my touch in the next
frame like 16 milliseconds too early and
this goes back and forth the brain is
trained to expect input at a certain
category if we just kept going back and
forth it's it's a bad experience we do
have a solution
it's called Android frame facing API TR
mentioned it before this is a bunch of
code that doesn't live inside Android it
lives as a library and you can download
it and try it
it supports support several of case
scenarios and it's very easy to
integrate and basically what it does is
there's any need there's a SWAT and
there's a set a bunch of parameters and
from there on it will take care of
making sure that your frame is nicely
presented right before the vsync and
also it will give you back callbacks
that you can use to start your game
logic right on time and everything you
put the two things together as long as
you're running in less than 30
milliseconds 33 you're good you will be
frame pace
perfectly at 30 frames per second and
that's all done by us you don't have to
care about what
devices because devices are slightly
different in the way they they treat the
Vissing can they treat the watch II just
don't have to care about it set your
frame interval as you're used to and
hope it goes it's available for both
Vulcan and OpenGL this is the mahkum
virtue it's in it set up swap interval
and then at some point the future swap
when you swap swap will return and it
will be presented and then you will have
a callback and you can start your game
logic straight away and the next you
think it also comes with Auto mode which
is kind of a peculiar mode to run in
there are situations where imagine your
game is running on a device is not as
performant so it mostly hit 30 frames
per second but sometimes it slows down
on a heavy scene and runs at 20 frames
per second well in the case that we just
saw earlier Oh a frame will come to 50
frames a second and the second one will
probably be a 16 because I arrived like
late but then I present another one
maybe it's gonna be a 33 I don't know
it's gonna be as fast as possible but
the frame will be choppy auto mode the
text is conditioned and so it's good
you're running at a stable 20 you're not
eating a stable 30 well I'm gonna slow
you down for the time being you can
reset at any time but when the frame
rate goes back to a more stable 30
different per second auto mode will bump
you up again it has the very good
consequence that you're also gonna save
battery because it will take certain
frames and we just slowed them down
just introduced ratings which means CPUs
and GPUs will have more chance to go to
sleep
that's how 30 frames per second looks
like this is a stable pacing now if you
come over there we can show you the
frame pacing API on one of the devices
we can go more in depth last but not
least this is a fun one because you have
phones that are packed with 4 megapixels
today and many games make sure that
they're gonna shade each megapixel each
pixel in the megapixel four megapixel
for reference is twice give or take a
full HD resolution which probably a year
ago was state-of-the-art console like
rendering sent to a 55 inch display and
there was looked like awesome this is a
great looking game it runs the full HD
when I was working on console I was
running a 720 720 is one megapixel now
phones we have four megapixel back there
you do not need to shade all of them
please don't because that's how I feel
about it
how do you recognize that you are
probably shading too many pixels where
you're gonna be GPU bound likely in
systrace there is a bar that gives you
the buffer count buffer count means that
the CPU is presenting a frame buffer
count goes to 1 the GPU does its own
thing just shade every single pixel then
the CPU is doing its work for the next
frame and if the GPU isn't finished yet
while the CPU will just put another
buffer in the queue just ready good good
to go and then wait what's probably and
the GPU will just try to catch up well
that's a situation where this buffer
count goes back to do another way of
saying it is well I have a frame that is
presented in 50 milliseconds let's
assume we don't have any frame pacing
issue here we already solved it well but
my friend time is taking 14 milliseconds
where the rest of the time is spent most
probably it's gonna be spent shading all
four megapixel this is very
straightforward to find out in a in
series I've seen a bunch looking exactly
like this now here's how you solve it
instead of a 3k by 1440 display instead
of rendering - all of it well crater in
the target that is molar and make sure
that you only stretch in one direction
reason is when you interpolate back it's
gonna be much higher quality and much
more cash right crash readiness help and
make sure that you're only rendering
your game word into this smaller and the
target no do you I the UI has generally
thin things and thin lines and phones
they don't scale well just render a full
resolution you eyes except for some
cases tend not to be too heavy so they
can go at full resolution and then
composite the tube in this case you're
saving 58% of the pixels this is
to be roughly a full-hd still on a
smaller screen it's gonna look amazing
it's still great nobody's gonna see it
if you are artist think that they're
gonna see the difference just tell them
that they won't if they still insist use
my trick
I never told artists that I was doing
any of these optimizations and they're
never spotted me that's why I'm still
here if they spotted me I probably
wouldn't my artists were awfully mean to
do the resizes cause sometime it's got
some GPU time because you have to
interpolate back to full fullscreen for
the final presentation a final
compositing and every Android device has
an Hardware composer that is not exposed
to the user which doesn't make me
particularly happy on the other hand any
game that will probably use this kind of
techniques and will probably be GPU
bound has some kind of post-processing
and tone mapping at the end where you're
doing I don't know some kind of blooming
some kind of torque correction well you
can do the process of stretching back to
full resolution in the post-processing
step it comes out not for free because
nothing is free but it's a nice way to
hide that time and to use it for
something useful this is a pretty common
way of doing the stretching back the
important thing that I want to stress
this point is that please stretch only
one direction
do not resize in two directions the
quality is much higher if you do it in
one direction
we've seen these four big I would say
performance pitfalls and I showed you
various ways to tackle it now you have
better knowledge of what you can
encounter in the field and a better
knowledge of how to solve these issues
they're pretty easy at the end of the
day except probably the last one I like
it doesn't take long to implement it and
use this knowledge now please go out
there and make some great games my name
is Francesco Karrueche
[Music]
you